Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
It's episode 96 today!
BAU BAU.
It's not just episode 96, it's also the end of the week already!
Weekend!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
The 96th episode right before the weekend!
BAU BAU!
I see some new Ruffians.
Ruffians!
For those of you that are just joining us for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by the Ruffians!
No.
Shiori. No.
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
This is your first FUWAMOCO Morning!
I wonder if we'll have any new new Ruffians on FUWAMOCO Morning 100.
That would be nice.
Well, Moco-chan!
Let's start off today with another FUWAMOCO Morning!
What do we have today?
De-den!
Did you decide to organize some dogs yourself after my stream the other day?
Is this one of the dogs you unlocked?
Pero... Moco-chan, is this a Pero Sighting?
Wait, what's with the description of Jun?
Cute ball of love.
Intelligent!
Oh my son!
No, this is Pero, you know?
I don't know.
I don't think he's a good dog to organize Ruffians.
You know?
Pero and a group of a bunch of dogs.
I don't think he's gonna get along with them.
Especially not Garibaldi.
No.
Plus, Pero's round.
Very round.
I think you know it.
If you try to organize him along with all those other dogs, they might start to go missing.
But, I guess that's a way to clean and organize too.
Get rid of the competition.
BAU BAU.
Organizing dogs just got darker, Ruffians.
Well, I hope you had some fun.
Yeah?
I would recommend though that you run an update on your game because I think something is... Something is broken!
Yeah, this may be.
BAU BAU!
We're going to be part of the hololive meet Super Karaoke Party together with some of our amazing senpai right there.
We're going to be singing a bunch of songs.
Some J-pop maybe, some anime songs maybe.
Before that, actually, we'll be meeting some very lucky Ruffians for the first time in two whole weeks!
Where are we?
We're super excited!
But also really nervous.
But we're gonna sing our hearts out!
But, uh, Moco-chan.
Ruffians, look at this!
De-den!
We've been on adjuncts going around Taipei!
You can hear us BAU BAUing from the streets of Abyss!
That's so cool, right?
Right!
I hope we haven't been too loud.
Really disturbed some grandmas and grandpas.
Yeah, but...
You know, it would be cute if they both BAU'd along with us, right?
Right!
Yeah, but Ruffians!
That's absolutely what we need you to do at the concert, okay?
Yeah, we hope we can hear your voice lots and lots, okay?
And FUWAMOCO!
We're going to do our best and hopefully the BAU BAU BYOU will get even stronger in Taipei!
BAU BAU!
Exciting!
Never BAU BAU too loud, no.
BAU BAU lots okay!
We'll be watching!
Waiting!
Listening!
All this stuff!
BAU BAU!
Well, there's been some other news with our whole Iain-senpai team.
You might not have heard, Ruffians, but Calli-senpai!
Calli-senpai just recently went away for surgery.
But she was really worried about it.
Understandably!
It all went well.
Yeah!
We were thinking about her lots and lots.
I know, we were sure she was really stressed about it.
And she even said that on Twitter she was so worried that she couldn't sleep at all before.
Yeah.
You know, we've been lucky ourselves.
We've never needed surgery before.
And hopefully it stays that way for us and all the Ruffians watching us today too!
Yeah!
It's scary.
But, you know, we hope that she heals up super duper fast and that she has a quick recovery.
Yeah!
We know she will!
And, well, we know it might be a little bit of a while before she's back, so eat her slice like normal.
It makes sense.
Yeah.
You need to take a break in these times you know.
We're sending you all our energy and fluffy and fuzzy vibes coming senpai!
BAU BAU!
Get better soon senpai!
Yeah, those times you need to take a break.
You better take a break.
Yeah.
Yeah, or FUWAMOCO are gonna find you.
She's doing well!
She looks good!
Right?
She looks good.
A beautiful photo.
I wanna take a photo like that.
No!
No, the thumbs up.
Thumbs up photo?
The thumbs up photo.
I don't have a thumbs up photo.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
But that goal is reaching 1 million subscribers before our first anniversary!
You know that, right?
Right.
Yeah!
We've been working hard to try to reach that goal!
Yeah.
Well, you might have noticed, especially during Fufu Week, that there's been some vertical streams, and that's a part of it too.
Right now, the official countdown.
We're 82 days away from our first year anniversary.
And right now, as you can see, Ruffians, we're at 831,000 Ruffians.
That's crazy amount of Ruffians!
Right!
Oh my gosh.
But you know, some Ruffians, it's the math.
You know, it is looking a little tricky.
A little tricky.
But we won't give up though!
No!
Yeah, we'll keep on working hard to meet the goal!
Yes!
But the number one thing to remember is that it's not about the journey.
What?
It's not about the goal!
It's about the journey!
Yes!
It's still early morning.
Don't open it!
It's about to dirty!
We are not misunderstanding Ruffians!
We are!
We can't have multiple- And so!
We're gonna continue to do our best no matter what!
Yes!
And you know, we're gonna continue to let everybody know that this is our big dream right now.
Yeah.
Because you know, if you have something important that you want to achieve, you need to say it.
Be proud!
Yeah.
Even if others say, you know, that's a silly dream.
Hai.
Yeah.
Nerissa, it's your dream.
We're gonna do it!
We're gonna reach this!
The FUWAMOCO way!
So hopefully, maybe Ruffians, we can give you a little bit of courage too to reach for your dreams!
To put your dreams into work.
And maybe not being so scared of making yourself a little bit vulnerable if it means that you can accomplish something very important to you.
If it matters to you, it's important.
Let's reach for our dreams together, okay?
Please support us on our journey to one million, okay?
BAU BAU!
It's important.
The journey.
The highway or the FUWAMOCO way.
The journey, right!
Yeah.
Your dream is to live peacefully.
Then let's have a peaceful, happy life.
BAU BAU!
I said it'd be nice to be peaceful.
But, Ruffians!
You noticed something, right?
This week has been a bit different compared to last, right?
Right!
Yeah!
It's been fluffy week!
Fluffy week!
My week!
Because Moco-chan, well, you've been doing your best to rest up your barker, right?
How's it been going, Moco-chan?
I've been trying.
What do you think?
The parker's owning a little bed of Ruffians.
I think so.
Yeah.
Trying.
Wow.
I'm really glad, Moco-chan.
Just make sure you keep resting lots and lots, okay?
I'm trying to rest but also be helpful.
Yeah.
Moco-chan, you're very helpful too.
But, uh...
Ruffians, there's one thing that I realized.
Like, in particular!
In particular.
There's a lot of things, but I have a big issue without you here with me, Moco-chan.
Really.
Yeah, other than the obvious things like, uh...
Now I have to play the game.
What?
I have to hold the controller, maybe sometimes- That's an issue!
It's a big controller.
My paws get tired.
My paws are not big!
Well, Ruffians, you know, Fuwawa, I'm not so good at left and right.
Right?
And then when it comes to clocks, sometimes that's a bit tricky too, right?
And, well, apparently, if it's just me all on my own, I also have a really hard time keeping track of time.
Somehow, I ended up playing Hitman for over 5 hours yesterday.
You know I gotta be carried away, huh?
I was gonna tell Fuwawa.
Remember, it's okay to play a bit longer today.
I knew it was a good thing I didn't say that.
Why?
You wouldn't play for 7 hours if I told you that.
I would have!
Water bottle.
It's FUWAMOCO Morning, you're not the host today.
Yes!
Hi.
So yeah, I got a bit carried away.
It was, you know, it was my first time playing Hitman.
And there was just so much to explore and try out.
So, I lost myself a little bit.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Yeah.
But it was amazing, right?
I really didn't think it would work, but it did.
It did.
Had to check it out.
Okay, Ruffians?
Hi!
Yeah, you really never ever know what Agent 437's gonna be up to, huh?
Hi.
It was a lot of fun.
Thank you, Ruffians, for the game suggestion too.
Hopefully one day we can play again together, Moco-chan.
You think I'd be good at it?
Agent 47.
47!
I don't know if I'd be good at it.
BAU BAU!
Not on the list.
Not on the list anymore.
Why?
Yeah.
I'm here.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
You might have noticed.
The other day while I was streaming.
I came in with a concern.
You know.
It's surprising.
We are Ruffians.
I was really scared, but you know, it's concerning when your little sister barges in, you know, when you're playing Touhou and focusing and just says, I made a mistake.
Right?
Yeah.
Well, you know, what I was trying to do was heat up my leftover noodles that I couldn't eat earlier.
You know, I know that you're supposed to pour hot water in them.
That's how we make them normally.
I read the instructions.
Especially, you know, it's new.
Instructions are important.
What are you supposed to do if you don't finish them all?
Anyways!
I tried heating them up.
So I put them in for a minute.
And then I walked away.
That's where my mistake was, huh?
Yeah.
Huh.
I came back to the cup!
And it looked like a big bubbly enemy from Hokuto no Ken!
You're already dead.
No!
My noodles are already dead!
The noodles were already dead!
It was really not good.
Yeah.
I wasn't expecting it at all!
Luckily though, it didn't explode everywhere or anything.
I just left it there.
Cooled down.
And then I tossed it.
Yeah, I didn't have to do anything.
I felt bad about throwing it out.
It's not good, Moco-chan.
It was a mistake.
But it's okay because you know, new foods are tricky, right?
What are you supposed to do, Ruffians?
Hi!
Did you just eat them whole then?
I guess that's your punishment for not eating them all right away.
Yahoo.
What if you don't have a bowl, hai?
Put it in a bowl, that's the solution.
What if you don't have a bowl still?
Hai!
What if you only have two mugs?
Put it in the mugs, Moco-chan!
It's gonna be a big mug!
BAU BAU!
But... There's been a misunderstanding.
Another misunderstanding.
We've been doing good, you know?
This one, Ruffians!
It's really embarrassing, so... I was just hoping, you know, that you'd forget about it!
But...
I keep on seeing very upset Ruffians on Twitter, so I thought I better address this.
I better apologize for this.
Finally, after a few weeks, Ruffians.
You know, we had a special FUWAMOCO Morning together with Koyori-senpai, right?
And, uh, she was talking about a yobai party and buying pajamas for us in the future.
Just special for the party!
And, uh, she said she was going to get sexy pajamas for me, for Fuwawa!
And I got all flustered and she's... And I...
I said, I'm not sexy, I'm Fuwawa!
And, uh, it seems that that might have made some Ruffians very angry.
But, uh, well, BAU BAU?
I'm just Fuwawa.
I guess.
If you think that's true, then, well,
It's rude of me to make statements like that, so... I'll try not to say things like that in the future, okay?
I won't say things that'll make you upset, okay?
BAU BAU!
Well, let's forget about that!
Right!
And let's take a look at the cutest Doggie of the Day today, my Moco-chan!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Sky!
BAU BAU!
So cute!
Look at the tongue!
Beautiful color!
I really want to touch the tongue.
Don't touch the tongue though, no.
But look, Sky!
Sky has the same fur color as us!
Is that because of Sky?
Did Sky make you sneeze, Moco-chan?
Well, Sky!
Sky's very curious and obedient, but a bit of a shy doggy too.
Shy Sky.
Yeah, Shy Sky.
She likes to explore new places!
And, uh, when she does, sometimes she comes back scared because there's new people too.
It's understandable.
I was thinking, Sky and Moco-chan have quite a bit in common, huh?
How does Sky BAU BAU?
I think it's... BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
I think it's accurate.
I think so.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Just like Moco-chan, Sky is doing their best to be brave and learn as much as they can about the world around them.
Just like me!
Yeah, just like you in particular.
I feel like... Hmm.
And Sky's doing their best too.
Please make sure that you hold her paw as she gets stronger, okay?
Especially around new people.
New people's always a bit rough, right, Moco-chan?
That's what the sniffle is for.
BAU BAU!
And next!
Today I went on a walk.
Ruffians!
Making sure to stretch those paws right.
That's the point!
Going out and seeing new things right.
We have De-den!
FUWAMOCO Abyssgard!
Look at the colors!
So beautiful.
Wow, what an amazing way to start out your day!
I hope you had a really great hike and that you got some good rest after it too.
Nice!
Rest in peace, okay?
BAU BAU!
You eat so BAU-tiful.
BAU-tiful.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
I wanna go on a hike now too.
That would be nice.
Oh, we also got another question.
The Question of the Day today is... De-den!
Hi, FUWAMOCO!
I think it's pretty safe to say that you both love music.
Just a bit, hoi.
But what's your favorite setting to listen to?
During walks?
While you do chores?
Or are you even sitting down in a big armchair doing nothing else like a true connoisseur?
FUWAMOCO!
We can't live without music.
No.
Music is us!
Yeah.
Right.
You know, we love listening to music a lot.
But, I think you know.
The best answer is that we're always listening to music.
The wonderful seven.
You know, while we sleep.
While we eat.
We just always have it running.
I feel like when we don't have it, when it's like off, suddenly the world's just like a little bit more... Yeah, it just, it brightens up our days so much.
Yeah, lots of energy from good tunes, you know?
So we hope, Ruffians, that
Maybe our music will make you feel the same way one day in the future.
But I don't know.
When we're like, we sit down and listen to it.
We don't just sit down and just do just that.
Think about things.
Does it count if you dance?
Is that the same as sitting down in an armchair and doing nothing while listening to music?
When we're doing our signatures on our postcards for you Ruffians, we're listening and singing to music too!
The music never stops.
It doesn't stop!
BAU BAU!
While I've let the Ruffians sit in a big armchair like a true connoisseur and listen to our covers.
Lifetime Showtime!
Do it okay, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions this week.
For your questions, your doggies, pero sightings even.
And your logs too!
As well as the FUWAMOCO's groups.
You know, FUWAMOCO Morning's a very, very special show that we made together, Ruffians.
Please continue to use the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians.
And next, we have some streams coming up.
Moco-chan, what's the next stream?
The next stream is...
Day!
Well, before this we're gonna be live in Taipei, so we're gonna do our best, but the singing doesn't stop because FUWAMOCO!
I'm having my first solo rock n' rawr party!
BAU BAU!
I'm really nervous.
I'm going to be all on my own.
It'll be fine.
You'll be good.
But I'm going to sing a bunch of my favorite songs.
This time without Moco-chan.
So maybe it'll be a little bit different.
I'll be different.
I'm looking forward to singing with you more.
That's you, Moco-chan.
I want to!
But this time, it's my solo Rock n' Rawr Party song.
I hope you'll be there, okay?
BAU BAU!
And today, Ruffians.
For Ruffians who are joining us later during the archive.
Oh, a schedule.
I forgot.
Because, well, after my Rock n' Rawr Party,
FUWAMOCO we have a homework day!
We're doing our best!
Ruffians, maybe you can catch up on some of the fluffy week that you might have missed.
And FUWAMOCO will catch up on some of the homework.
That is always true.
Yeah, we didn't miss.
It just needs to get done.
BAU BAU!
And for Ruffians joining us in the archive, here is your FUWAMOCO word for today!
It's BAU BAU!
Get better, Calli!
BAU BAU!
Such a nice co-word today, huh?
It's a good co-word.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Senti!
BAU BAU!
Apollon!
Choufa!
BAU BAU!
Ayeron!
Xiaomi.
BAU BAU!
Alice.
Waffle.
BAU BAU!
Grimful.
TaroTaro.
BAU BAU!
Justic.
Substitute!
BAU BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!